I wish I had that
because it's so lonely at the top
and it's so lonely when you're
a high achiever
and it's so hard for you
to admit that you need help.
And just having someone to talk to
that has been there
and walk the walk,
not just talk the talk
is a big difference.
Ilana Golan,
welcome to 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Thank you.
It's amazing to be here.
I've been watching
your shows every time
and I just love it so.
That warms my heart.
Thank you very, very much.
It's an honor and a pleasure
to have you here as a guest.
An entrepreneur at heart.
An entrepreneur with the ventures,
with an acquired venture
behind you already.
But with a lot of different,
really interesting transitions
along your career.
And I'm particularly excited
to talk about your journey,
the insights you've gained
from the twists and turns,
the ups and downs
leading up to Golan Ventures
and to CareerLeap,
which obviously is probably one
of the most important conversations
to be held in the midst
of a pandemic.
So, Ilana, take it away.
Who are you
and how do you even get started
into this world?
So, engineer, tech,
you know, I've been in tech for a while
and kind of moved up the chain
from big companies like Intel
to smaller companies and startups.
Product, sales, kind of moved up
the chain all the way to vice president.
All across the board.
Leap to entrepreneurship
with some ups and downs.
Eventually, you know,
my company was acquired.
I moved to the venture side,
and now I'm a public speaker
and Forbes contributor.
And I decided to just
take all this knowledge
and help others do the same.
Because I realized
that leaping in career is something
that I somehow know how to do
and I want to help others.
So.
I love it.
You ended up getting
to the realization
that you really love helping people,
understand what they can do
and deal with that difficult moment.
I have to say that many entrepreneurs
that I know, most entrepreneurs
that I know,
they are tech executives,
they've had businesses before,
they don't turn to helping others
as a full time job.
So, what really motivated you
to go and decide,
now I'm going to spend
most of my time helping other people
realize what they need to do?
It's amazing question.
You know, and I honestly contemplated
with this for a long time,
like it's something I wanted to do.
And I was somewhat scared to do it.
And it was like somewhat,
I used to be kind
of this business woman
and I going to be what,
like a coach
or I wasn't even sure I like coaching,
and I don't even see myself
as a coach.
I see myself more
as a growth strategist.
So, I wasn't really sure
if this is the right thing,
but I found myself
just helping a lot of people
on the phone.
And honestly,
you can't help a person
to leap in their career over coffee.
Like it just doesn't work.
First of all, you can't scale and be,
it's not a one time thing.
Like it's a journey
and you have to be
there with them on the journey.
And, you know, and I was looking
for a good way to do that.
And eventually I just found
that I love doing this.
I love to see people transform.
I love to see people change.
And I wish I had that
because it's so lonely at the top.
And it's so lonely when
you're a high achiever
and it's so hard for you
to admit that you need help.
And just having someone to talk to
that has been there
and walk the walk,
not just talk the talk
is a big difference.
Walk me through that relationship.
That conversation
that I might have with you
as I need to make that leap.
Now and before that
dumb it down for me a little bit,
what does it mean for a person
to want to make that leap?
Does it mean that
they are looking for different jobs,
they're not fulfilled,
they think they can get higher
to where they are today?
What does that entail?
Yeah. Basically, bingo.
Like it's everything you just said, right?
I mean, it's usually
the high achievers, right?
It's the people who are looking forward
and saying, you know what,
there must be more to life
than what this is.
And I could be doing more.
And I want to live more of a legacy
and I want to make more of an impact.
And I want to do something that matters.
And, you know, I'm probably
at the last quarter of my career
and I need to make it count.
At least two three quarters, Ilana.
At least two, three quarters.
So, yes.
So, I want to make it count.
And you know,
and I remembered it for myself
because I used to wake up
in the middle of the night
and like, it can't be
that this is it.
Like it can't be.
I'm overachiever and yes,
I'm doing amazing things.
But what's next?
Like what's the next big thing?
And, you know, just
So, what I'm hearing from you
is something that I'm starting to pick up
from all the different episodes.
And that is some of that
innate curiosity and passion
that is burning inside you.
And you're saying, yes.
I'm doing all these things,
I'm vice president of this
and I'm executive of this,
and I founded this company.
But you're looking
to really understand
how do I make that tangible impact
on somebody
and know that impact.
So, my question then Ilana is,
what is that impact?
What is the impact of helping people
make that leap in their careers?
How does that even translate
to tangible impact?
Right.
So, I mean, first of all,
just seeing someone
that they're basically
almost turned off
when you meet them, initially.
You know, they're unfulfilled,
they're unmotivated.
They honestly take it usually home.
They're not as happy as a person.
They don't exercise as much
or not as healthy as they want to be.
Like everything is kind of
like a downhill spiral.
And I was in that downhill spiral.
Right?
You were?
So, I feel it. Yeah.
Why were you in the downward spiral?
Story time.
Oh my God.
So, yeah.
So, I mean in a quick few seconds.
We have time Ilana, we have hours.
I know. You're like counting.
So, I was already vice president.
I started the US operation
technical operation
of an Israeli startup here.
It grew to 15 million.
It was an amazing success.
And then I wanted kind of that
what's next. Right?
So, I wanted to leap to entrepreneurship.
Somebody I knew from the Technion
wanted to do this together,
build it kind of in the off hours,
raise money, $800,000.
And right when I
basically did a big party
for my previous job
and to tell them about the startup,
the same day he kicked me out.
So, he took the money,
kicked me out of business,
and at some point
within seconds or a day,
I was left with nothing
like no job, no salary,
no startup, no investment.
And I felt like the earth
just like fell from under me. Right?
So, it's that point.
It's like, sorry for the language,
the holy shit moment.
It's like you wake up and,
what do you do?
Like what do I do?
Do I look for a job?
Do I look for a co-founder?
Or do I start a business?
Like what do you do.
And you know, you don't have
to have these big moments
to really feel like,
oh my God, I need more than this.
And I've had those small moments
in my life as well.
Like you as an engineer,
you're many times stuck
as a technical person.
And then you know,
you move to like product
and then you're stuck as a product.
So, you keep on getting stuck
because you're good at it.
Right?
The question is,
how do you get unstuck?
And it's a lot about reputation
and network these days.
So, that's really what plays a role.
And the way people
are finding opportunities is different
than it used to be.
So, people will reinvent themselves
every year or two.
And it's add to your skill. You need to learn.
Right.
So, we're talking about a new reality.
You know, it's not just
that we're living in covid times,
but I believe the trend,
especially in the tech sector,
is that every two years
people change positions
for good and for bad,
which means that
a lot more people have
the potential to reach
that unstuck moment.
Because if all of my friends
are advancing every two years
and it's my turn to advance like,
holy shit, I need to be advancing
just like my friends.
How do you get unstuck?
Walk me through some of the,
you know, some of the big pointers
for anybody that may be stuck
that is present here with us.
Right.
And I'll say a few things.
So, first of all,
again, we will reinvent ourselves
every year or two.
And it's a skill,
but nobody teaches you the skill.
And what's more interesting is that
the roles that you're looking at,
especially in the tech sectors,
nobody really taught you marketing
or that kind of skills,
or that kind of management.
Like, you don't learn that in school.
It's really experiences.
And then you get into
that chicken and egg.
Like, but you don't have the experience.
So, how can you do that. Right?
So, the interesting part there is,
how do you fast track
to get those experiences
so that you can claim it
and you can have the confidence
and you can build that reputation
so that your network
will open these opportunities your way.
And that's how you leap.
So, the unstuck is basically
to figure out, first of all,
what you want to do
and which is crucial.
Sometimes I look at it as experiments,
just like startups experiment
to figure out their market, you know,
like, where they want to go next.
Your go-to-market strategy,
that's the same thing.
You experiment with your career.
You figure out one thing,
you try it out.
You see if it works.
You start building your
reputation network accordingly.
If you don't like it, change it.
The beautiful thing is,
I say it to the leapers,
In 2007, we all became a media company,
and whether you like it or not,
if nobody hears from you
the assumption is that
you have nothing to say.
Right?
So, you know but we can leverage this.
We can basically leverage
to tell a new story about ourselves
and its power.
Wow.
How much of that is more is emotional
versus, you know,
mental and intellectual and tangible,
and on just saying, okay.
here's the pros, here's the cons,
and here is what Ilana tells me
that I need to do
so I should just go do it?
So, what is the mindset of a person
who is a leaper in your mind?
It's a great question
because I think it's exactly
all everything that you just said.
Right?
It's not enough
to just give information these days.
I mean, you have information
on YouTube, right, you don't need to--
Right.
So, it's not about information.
It's really about the transformation
and it's about,
how do you get
to that transformation.
How do you get that kind of ability.
How do you get inspired by people.
How do you learn about opportunities
you didn't even know about.
Right?
Because when you're in corporate
and all you see
is that senior director role
that you want,
you didn't even know
that you could mentor
in startup accelerators
and join boards
and be adviser like
you didn't even know
that these things exist.
Right?
So, it's really about opening your mind
to what's possible,
but also giving you the courage
and the inspiration to move on
and that kind of ability
to keep pushing.
Because when you're scared,
you're going to tend
to lean back to your comfort zone.
So, it's really about everything.
It's a lot of mindset, really.
It's fascinating.
At the end, it's all about fulfillment.
And it's all about the pyramid of Maslow.
Right?
That you want to reach that hierarchy.
And I guess one of the most
difficult parts of it is knowing,
acknowledging that you're stuck.
Right?
I'm assuming that
it's very easy to get into a routine
and sort of bending out
because it's first of all,
it's comfortable to have a position,
even if you're a little bit stuck in it,
you're stuck often in comfort,
especially in our industry.
So, there's a big part
from when you are stuck
to when you go to Ilana Golan
and she helps you get unstuck.
I agree.
And honestly, I do.
The big thing that I tell people is
that life is in phases.
And in different phases
different things will
be important for us.
And sometimes it's really
about finance and comfort and balance.
And that's okay.
You know, as long as you're admitting
that this is what's important for you
right now and this part is okay,
then it's okay.
Right?
So, when I was in a big corporate
and I knew that I'm going
to have two children
and I'm going to take
two maternity leave
and I wanted to run an Ironman
and all sorts of things,
then, you know,
it was okay for me to be stuck
because I wasn't stuck.
I was doing the things
that I love to do.
Right?
So, you know, to some extent
you need to decide
what's your must haves.
And once you define
your must haves,
you need to say, okay,
so now this is
what's important for me
and maybe its reputation
and maybe its recognition,
maybe its growth
and maybe its more pay,
whatever it is, right?
Now, go chase it.
So, the question
that I have to ask is,
executive in tech,
two kids and an Ironman,
how does that work?
Well, first of all, I have to admit
the Ironman was before the two kids.
But yes.
No. I am, I need to be busy.
I see that.
I can see that very clearly.
But that's life, you know, like,
I just want to make things happen.
You know, I decide on a goal
and I go pursue it.
But I like to take people with me,
you know, and that's the beautiful part.
So, now that I'm surrounded
with phenomenal leapers
that are like, you know,
I see them growing,
I see them fulfilled,
I'm seeing their eyes
like spark, like it's just,
something that I don't think
I've ever felt before.
And it's, you know,
it's first of all, it's fulfillment.
It's you feel like you're impactful.
And beyond that, it's you know,
it's the financial freedom
and the geography freedom
that I wanted for myself
so that I can keep on traveling the world
and still inspiring
and making a lot of money.
So, it's great.
I love it.
Circling back because
that is a question
that I'm fascinated by.
I'm assuming
that most people in the world
that I mean,
I'm assuming that the people
that are already talking to you
that are stuck,
they are the top percentile
that have acknowledged it
and are making that leap.
But there is a whole level of people
that are stuck
and they're just
maybe they're not
they don't know it
or they don't know
what to do about it.
How can you tell if a person is
exhibiting the symptoms of stuckness?
Or the person who has the potential
to make that leap
but just doesn't realize it yet?
It's a great question.
I mean, first of all,
I have to say
that I accept roughly
1 out of 5 people
that I talk to.
Really?
Yeah. I am very, very picky.
And the reason is
I want the people
to have enough of
the goal needs to be
realistic, but high.
Right?
And they need to be committed.
They need to be driven.
They need to be coachable,
resourceful, etc.
Right?
So, there is a certain type of people
that I like working with.
It's definitely more the high achievers
in that top percentile.
You know, people sometimes, again,
they will feel stuck for a while.
But sometimes, like I said,
it's comfortable.
And we said that. Right?
But sometimes
it literally wakes you up
in the middle of the night
or wakes you up.
You see that you're anxious
or you're not yourself
and you're not
the best version of yourself.
And at that point, it's you know,
it took me many years
to ask for help.
Now I have my own coaching
and I pay crazy amounts for it.
But it takes me higher.
Right?
And, you know,
I think it took me years
to understand that it's okay,
even though I'm just like
Air Force Girl. Right?
That I probably shouldn't ask for help
and I should just figure it out
and you know, like figure,
kind of prove that I can.
But actually, when I ask for help,
it's going to take me much faster
and much better. Right?
So, it took me many years
to figure it out.
And now I you know,
I want to find the people
that will, you know,
if I give them a hand,
they will take it
and they will work hard
and they will be committed
and they'll get tremendous results.
It sounds like
it takes a lot of courage
to do both of these sides
to play on both roles, right?
Yeah. It's courage all along.
Right?
Because every time you leap,
you're going to be out
of your comfort zone.
So, the question is
what kind of comfort zone
and how big of a leap
are you going to go for?
And leap is scary.
I mean, you're going to do
by definition,
it's something you haven't done before.
By definition, it's something bigger.
And you need to decide
that this is what you want for yourself
and for your family
and for your fulfillment.
So,
yeah, it's not so.
One of the things
that I'm still thinking
from a few sentences ago
is you said
of the term coachable.
I never thought of the coaching as
it's a two sided market.
It's not just that somebody
is willing to pay.
And so, therefore,
it's going to be a good fit.
But you need somebody
that's coachable,
somebody that you will
enjoy working with,
because just as you're coaching them,
I'm sure that a part of it
is you're talking about
how you're getting
the fulfillment from them
and you're getting motivated
by seeing them progress.
And so, you need people
that will feed you
that motivation as well, right?
Absolutely.
If I'm not 200% confident
that I can take them higher,
I don't want to work with them,
not because I'm a jackass,
just because I want to see those results.
What I really care about
is their transformation,
I mean, I've had enough, like,
whether one person joins or not
that's not going to move
the needle for me.
But it will be good than to see people
that don't get the results.
So, yeah, I love this.
Just wonderful.
Ilana, thank you so much
for being so generous with your time.
It was lovely to have you here.
Before we leave,
I need to ask you for three words
that you would use
to describe yourself.
I think I even said it.
Making things happen.
Yeah, I'm the type,
it doesn't matter if it's a trip
or an adventure
or entrepreneurship
or whatever.
I'm going to make something happen
and I'm going
to take people along with me.
So, yeah.
Amazing.
Ilana, thank you very much.
Toda Raba.
Best of luck
and thank you for helping
a lot of people along the way.
It's really great. Take care.